what is a world with China as the sole
dominant superpower look like I mean a
little bit underlying our discussion is
this kind of idea that us is the good
guys and China is the bad
guys first of all you know the you know
dividing the world into good guys and
bad guys seems to
somehow miss the Nuance of this
whole human civilization project we're
undertaking but what does the world look
like where China is the dominant sole
superpower in a unipolar
world well I I don't tend to think of
the world in terms of good guys and bad
guys as a good realist I I think that
you know states are States they're all
black boxes you know I don't
discriminate between democracies and
autocracies but having said that I am an
American right and as an American I'm
interested in the security of my country
the survival of my country so I want the
United States to be the most powerful
state in the world which means I want
the do United States to dominate the
Western Hemisphere I want us to be a
regional hedgemon and I want to make
sure that China does not dominate Asia
the way we dominate the Western
Hemisphere it's not because I think
we're the good guys and they're the bad
guys uh if I were Chinese and I were in
Beijing and I were xiin National
Security adviser I'd tell him what we
got to do is make sure we dominate the
world or dominate our region and then do
everything we can to undermine America's
position in the Western Hemisphere right
that that be my view uh so I guess you
could say I do view the world in terms
of good guys and bad guys because I'm an
American and more like us and Them
versus yeah it's us and them that's
that's a nice way to put it yeah it's US
versus them not so much good guys versus
bad guys is it possible to have a St
peaceful world with a good balance of
power with where it's China and us a
superpowers you it's a bipolar world no
longer unipolar yeah okay so you're
hypothesizing a world where they
dominate Asia yeah and we dominate the
Western Hemisphere I I believe there
would be uh a great deal of security
competition intense security competition
between those two superpowers the
definition of intense matters here so it
could be
small small military conflicts or it
could be extremely large unstable
military conflicts right well conflict
let's use the word War okay so I I
distinguish between security competition
and War and what I'm telling you is
you'll have an intense security
competition where there's no shooting
where if there's shooting it's mainly
proxies that are doing the fighting much
like the Vietnam War right uh or you
could have a case where one of those
superpowers was involved in a war
against a proxy of the other superpower
Korean War think the Korean War the
United States for the Chinese who were
allied with the Soviets at the time but
uh a war between the United States and
China just like a war between the United
States and the Soviet Union during the
Cold War that's what you really want to
invoid avoid so I think you'd have an
intense security competition right you'd
have wars involving proxies of each of
those two superpowers and you would
probably have some Wars where one of the
superpowers was involved in a proxy
right with the other super one of the
super other superpowers proxies so it
seems likely then if that's the case
then it would be Taiwan is the proxy and
us fighting China through the proxy of
Tai what yeah well that would assume the
United States but you want to remember
you're hypothesizing a situation where
China dominates Asia oh already has
dominated yeah it's already dominated
Taiwan uh I see we we well where do you
find the proxies Australia the Middle
East could be a good case oh wow right
Persian Gulf right oh boy and then our
discussion of Israel becomes even more
dramatically yeah well Israel Israel
gets involved I think I think in this
scenario if you're talking about a us
China competition right and you're
talking about the Middle East I think
it's the gulf it's it's the Saudis the
Iranians the Iraqis it's the oil don't
you think it could be Israel versus Iran
with
some very 1984 kind of dramatic
Partnership of Iran Russia and China
versus United States Europe and um
Israel I think that's possible yeah I
think that's possible yeah now that I I
mean I hadn't thought about it and uh
until you said it but yeah I think that
that that is possible is isn't that
terrifying yeah well that you know in
your scenario where China already
dominates Asia and we dominate the
Western Hemisphere uh I think you start
talking about where are the most likely
places uh that the United States and
China go head-to-head uh or or fight
through proxies uh I I think it is the
GOL for the Middle East and the scenario
that you posit
it